Hola Rosa Qué tal efectivamente la
posición tuvo un fuerte triunfo en las
elecciones locales podemos decir que el
Comitán el partido histórico defiende
una relación madura con china una
relación sin conflicto no es un partido
que defienda una Unión con china volver
a China comunista pero sí una una
política no independentista y no de
provocar al gobierno comunista chino
Bueno ahí sí tiene más que hablar porque
efectivamente hay elecciones
presidenciales en 2024 Isai no puede
reelegir Entonces esto también si bien
no se puede pronosticar porque
efectivamente en 2018 ganaron Comitán y
en 2020 ganó 6 pero yo diría que estos
puede afectar en la sucesión porque el
candidato que perdió en tyga de ministro
de salud de SAE una persona bastante
reconocida por su política en la
pandemia y fue Derrotado no en la
elección municipal O sea que nos puede
dejar algunas pistas para ver cómo se
organizan los partidos con vistas al
futuro de la lección presidencial